foreign
CNBC article and uh this is written uh
in kind of the first person uh a
reporter and I'm just going to skip all
over that and get to the reality here
over half of Americans earning
more than a hundred thousand dollars a
year are living paycheck to paycheck
this is according to a recent report by
payments and Lending Club
uh earning more than a hundred thousand
dollars a year would put you well ahead
of the median American household which
brings in seventy four thousand seven
hundred eighty dollars
so assuming you're an individual with
dependence at salary would qualify you
as upper class
through three different definitions
um but if we skip the whole upper class
middle class all that
we're talking about people
making over a hundred thousand dollars a
year that are living paycheck to
paycheck
according to data from the Bureau of
Labor Statistics you'd have to earn
about 129 thousand dollars today to have
the same purchasing power that a salary
of a hundred thousand had just a decade
ago
so how far your dollar goes depends on
cost of living
and George we say things like cost of
living but then that just assumes it's
like well this is just what it is no you
determine your cost of your living just
because you live in one region of the
country or the other doesn't mean that
you have no responsibility or no say in
your cost of living and you were just
telling me something oh which I want to
cite because I think this is a great
example and you said that you were in a
little which I don't know why you do
this but that's not the point you were
in a little uh little tiff if you will
with someone on social media today and
the guy was giving you the business
about how in the world can you say that
you can live in a New York City on a
hundred thousand dollars and your reply
was yeah here I always think of this
Mark Twain quote never argue with an
idiot they will drag you down and beat
you with experience and that is what I
do every time I go in the comments
section I know and uh so this guy we
posted a clip from my YouTube channel
and it was about how
people make a hundred thousand dollars
feel broke and it's because of debt it's
because of their lifestyle and he chirps
and going this guy doesn't understand
that there's areas of the country where
you can't live on a hundred thousand
dollars and I went bro if I didn't have
any debt I could show anyone how to live
on 100 Grand in New York City I promise
you that
here's what grinds my gears can in this
article it says thanks to a combination
of federal state and local taxes along
with sky-high cost of living a hundred
thousand dollar salary New York City is
worth more like 35 000 smart asset found
I'll show you smart asset here's the
deal you can include cost of living and
just take that out of someone's check
um so when it comes down to it let's say
you're effective tax rate effective tax
rate not marginal what you actually
ended up paying even in New York City
was you know 25 30 even 35 that still
leaves you with about six grand
take-home pay
now New York City rent of course it's
going to be really high now if you're a
single young person live with roommates
I live with roommates all the way up
until I was married I know it's not fun
I know you'd rather have a beautiful
Penthouse in New York City on your own
and if you want to own a home you may
not be able to afford a wonderful single
single-family home in the best
neighborhood right now you might have to
get a condo that's 20 minutes further
out but people don't want to make these
sacrifices Ken and they love to complain
about inflation and cost of living and
yes those are astronomically high but I
truly think the answer is debt lifestyle
and lifestyle creep there's no more you
make the more you spend we all think we
can't live without debt well you got to
have a car payment right and these
student loans I mean you can't get rid
of these things well unless you know
what let me just throw something out
there I'm not gonna go too deep down
this this road but this article mentions
Tennessee where we live I love the state
of Tennessee one of the many reasons I
love state of Tennessee is because they
don't tax us on our income no state
income tax and I just got to point this
out people griping and complaining about
the cost of living in New York and they
basically say because Tennessee doesn't
tax earned income a Memphis residents
what they pick the city of Memphis
earning a hundred thousand dollars takes
home seventy four thousand after federal
state taxes and because the city's cost
of living is 14 below the national
average blah blah blah blah blah this
feels like it's always difficult guess
what you can move
you can move
and if you and if you move here can I
just say this you should maybe vote like
we vote because that's why we don't have
a state income tax don't go voting to
have an income tax and I'm not I'm not
listen I know people get nervous I'm not
going to get political on one side of
the aisle or other I'm just going to
tell you the facts are the facts you can
move or you can change the way you vote
what are we going to gripe about taxes
there's a pretty clear choice most of
the time so I just get so irritated with
all this cost of living and taxes this
and taxes that well guess what
you ever say in it move and if you move
vote differently and then and then spin
differently there's your three points
George you can't just make it all about
the money you also got to decide where
do I want to live why do I want to live
there what does that mean and if you
want to live there go make some more
money that's the whole point but no they
want you to give them more money and so
that doesn't work that we should just
feel entitled to live in New York City
for fun regardless of our income that's
an insane take sure I'll call Stacy on
the way home today hey babe we're going
to the upper east side of Manhattan
because I want to and and now
everything's just going to happen and
forget the numbers we just we're going
to gripe about it the entire time or you
know you just can't Manifest this stuff
it's it's it's mind-boggling I know I'm
getting grumpy but it's just
mind-boggling to me I love grumpy Kent
it's my favorite you're getting better
folks if you're just joining us George
is not emotional today his voice is
coming and going he doesn't know when
it's coming he doesn't know when it's
going but when you talk for a living
it's just exhausting they don't tell you
that much but we have a good time so
here's the deal what we have to
understand is when we started this
article we laid out some data that we
have more hundred thousand dollar in
over earners than ever
that are living paycheck to paycheck
and the reality is is that the more that
we make the more we are tempted to spend
this is The Human Condition and so it
comes back to something that Dave Ramsey
has said for decades
it's not about math
it's about the behavior it's the person
in the mirror and and and when we can
get to a point where we go you know what
I'm going to sacrifice I'm going to wait
a little bit
sacrificing waiting ends up winning but
when we don't sacrifice when we don't
wait and we say give me now I want this
now we make decisions and before we know
it we have literally painted ourselves
into a financial corner where then the
only option is massive sacrifice
and massive misery you've heard the
calls on the show well people are going
we got to sell everything we have to
move yeah because we're broke yeah and
then what is our prescription to them
you know we're saying you're not going
to see the inside of a restaurant for
two years unless you work there that's
not fun
but the more we make decisions based on
what we want now versus what we want
long term the more we get ourselves into
trouble and that's what's going on it is
unconscionable to me that a hundred
thousand dollar earner is living
paycheck to paycheck because in America
you can make changes you can change
where you live you can change where you
work you can change how you spend this
idea that I've got to have more money
and I'm griping and complaining going
inflation it's so high and it used to
use this and I shouldn't get adjusted my
income
you're gonna lose your job
you're gonna lose your job no company
can pay you commensurate to inflation it
is impossible they will go out of
business you don't so asking for
something like that is mind-numbingly
stupid yeah it all comes down to delayed
gratification and here's the thing we
can always look back and go man in the
1950s a hundred thousand dollars that
would turn into twenty thousand you
can't keep looking at the past well
you'd have been broke in the 1950s too
yep that's the problem you gotta look at
reality and go what can we do next
knowing what we know what can we control
we can control where we live how much we
work what our income is that's in our
control